retired Admiral sandy Winnefeld is a CBS
News military and homeland security
analyst he was vice chairman of the
Joint Chiefs of Staff when secretary
mattis led the US Central Command
Admiral good morning good morning John
and well what do you make of secretary
mattis's letter well first of all of all
of the people who have left or are about
to leave this administration this is
probably the most concerning not only
did Jim mattis get to the department on
a good trajectory to restore its
readiness and lethality in the face of
all threats he also helped buttress our
allies at a very difficult time for
relations with allies and perhaps most
importantly when all those national
security decisions were being made in
the White House we could all take
comfort that well at least Jim mattis is
in the room and he's not going to be in
that room much longer as his letter
points out he had some fundamental
disagreements with the president and as
the old adage says either support your
boss or resign and he chose to resign
before he got fired and Merle you know
secretary mattis what do you make though
of the fact that he made such a broad
and sweeping set of statements in this
letter secretary Madison is it knows the
chain of command he knows what what
you're supposed to do and so how do you
frame it with respect to what you know
about secretary mattis well I think that
secretary mattis has been working on
this letter for a while clearly there
was a lot of tension in the relationship
beginning probably all the way back to
the withdrawal from the Iran nuclear
agreement and a whole host of other
challenges as well whether it was
transgender personnel in the military or
a parade down Pennsylvania Avenue or
trips to the southern border I think
that this was building up and in
Jim Madison's mind and his letter uses
integrity Jim mattis is nothing if not a
man of integrity and I think it's a very
important letter that will go down in
the history of this nation as you
mentioned earlier a historian said this
is the first time a Secretary of Defense
has resigned so it's clear that pulling
out of Syria was the final straw for
general mattis let me ask you about some
unintended consequences from that
decision because one headline that came
shortly after came from the Kurds who
said that because of that they would
have to release some 32
Isis prisoners which would be
devastating for the region but also for
Europe what is your reaction to these
unintended consequences well there is an
awful lot swirling around the whole
Syria situation not the least of which
is the brutal regime of Bashar al-assad
and Iran and Russia which support him
but also the potential for a return to
instability in eastern Syria and in fact
western Iraq so it is a very bitter pill
to swallow to more or less abandon the
Kurds who have done most of the fighting
out there against ISIL and all those
unintended consequences you talk about
release of prisoners less humanitarian
aid being delivered to people in that
region we're gonna feel the effects for
quite some time sandy I'm finished I'm
struck by the phrase you just said loses
integrity what are the broader
implications for morale quickly well I
think that the US military will look at
this with a little bit of shock and
dismay but I would also tell you there's
a lot of really good leadership still
residing in the Pentagon we've got a
great deputy secretary we've got a
terrific chairman and I think that the
Department will be fine but it is a
little bit of a jolt to the system to be
sure all right Admiral Winnefeld thanks
so much for being with us